you see you stayed in airbnb have you
stated many airbnbs in japan um
not really yeah i mean because like 90
of them got [ __ ] axed yeah so for the
olympics uh
the japanese government changed the the
rules around airbnbs basically just
gutting them yeah and making it so that
you had to make it you did follow a lot
of but they basically made it so you had
to follow hotel rules like you had to
have like the fire escape and like the
floor lit up to the yeah it's they made
it they basically made the rules
impossible on purpose where you couldn't
turn a profit like reasonably basically
because i have stayed in an airbnb yeah
i stayed in one as well the first time i
visited it was super cheap you get like
what do we get me and alan got the
airbnb for what like
it was really cheap like 150 bucks yeah
but it was like a really really small
room i remember but it was right in
chennai
oh remember was that the one yeah that
was the one i got really sick
what i want to know okay so this is like
i think the first time you'd been to
japan it was my very first time very
first time
i was so confused i just turned up in
this place yeah i heard the instructions
for this airbnb that i didn't understand
had my luggage and i was like what the
[ __ ] is going on yeah i was so confused
like yeah
and of course connor flies over and the
very first thing we do uh once connor
and alan come over is that we go to
karaoke and we stay all night well we
weren't going to right so what happened
was that i took you guys to an izakaya
oh yeah i was only going to meet because
you guys were like oh we're too sleepy
you're probably just going to go to bed
and then i think you me and joey were
like well sit well i think because it
was my first time going to japan i was
like
sorry finally i could show this i was
like there's someone wrestling let's go
and get drinks yeah because i was like
jet lagged and so was conor i think i
mean i mean you were jet lagged
you were running off you were running on
the excitement of yeah of course being
in japan for the first time show me
around let's go let's go drink so then
joey julie had like a very uh like i
told you
during the weekday where they have 100
yen beers yeah yeah yeah and connor was
mine was just [ __ ] i was like a
dollar yeah i was like this is insane
this is like 60p this is like beauty
prices not even uni prices don't even
get this low this is this was insane
yeah
it's a beer right legit like a legit
beer
yeah we were drinking and then mommy and
jerry were getting drunk yeah i think
they were gone and uh we we had just
landed and we were like they were like
you know what no we don't want to miss
out so then they came and started
drinking and then we went out of karaoke
yeah and then we stayed last night when
i got very
i know joey joey got a very sick if you
know what i mean i had to stay around
your place um who slept on the floor
dance editor and so this was november
yeah no yeah november yeah no january
it was like
basically it was [ __ ] freezing yeah
it was really cool we had to have the ac
running in the room problem was is that
there was a door there was literally no
room for anyone else to sleep in this
room of two people yeah because i
remember going to your place i'm just
like how the [ __ ] did you fit three
people in here it's literally a shoebox
yeah yeah so basically allen had to
sacrifice his bid for me and he slept in
the hallway
allen the tallest [ __ ] yeah and
by by hallway it was literally like just
a single like very
like it was slipped on the floor it was
like a human-sized corridor you could
not like fit anything more than just
like a [ __ ] it was like it was like
minus five it was a really cold yeah he
was just like like i because i wasn't
aware that allen had you know given up
the bed and slept
because
i was out i was like throwing up all
night and it wasn't until i woke up that
morning
and i kind of came to and i was like
where the [ __ ] am i
and then i saw connor in his bed on the
other side and i was like oh okay i'm in
there airbnb and i was like where's alan
and then i just saw this like lump
yeah in the hallway yeah yeah like just
like just this lump of like blankets
he's that one friend who's like the
nicest guy when you're like sick or like
when you drink too much he's always
gonna go back
i threw up on time and he and even
though he was drunk he cleaned it all up
and i just went back to bed
that was the uh very first time i hung
out with you the first time i met him as
well yeah first first time first time
you guys met right yeah and he cleaned
up my
me throwing up absolute chat
that's how i know like from that point
onwards i was like amazing friends with
him because i was like this guy's got my
best yeah
no one else will do nothing i would
never do that for someone i'm like i'm
i'm going back to bed yeah yeah you can
deal with this too because i remember
remember it was like kind of like a
house party we had in england where we
kind of like rented out an airbnb
um and just like caught up with other
friends
and you were like the new guy i was like
20 as well so i was still like yeah
let's drink way too much yeah i remember
alan telling the story of like i think
everyone was passed out and it was just
you and alan awake and your guys was
like sleeping on the sofa or something
and then like i think he made eye
contact with you have you made eye
contact with him and he just started
laughing and then he just watched you
and you just like looked at him laughed
and just chundered everywhere
you made some drink with like really
budget energy drink and that was like
all right from that day
yeah i swore never to drink budget
energy drink even even energy drink is
bad enough but the budget one where it's
like 50 cents for two liters is like
it's like brake fluid like no one like
of course you're going to throw up
drinking that stuff i'm glad i did
because i didn't have to digest yeah
exactly for jesus
yeah we have a mate from home uh who's
now
like discovered a new cocktail is what
he calls it it's not a cocktail it's
literally like okay tell me how
disgusting this sounds it's boost so a
boost so
budget red bull yeah uh boost and red
wine
oh my god
that's oh jesus does he have like a
functioning like taste buds and i'm just
like
i thought we grew out this in university
man that can't be no not even uni
students stooped out loaded like i think
if you did that in france you'd be
deported yes rick i'm calling you out
right now it's disgusting stop trying to
get me to drink it that's so vile
yeah
what would i even take like could you
even taste the energy drink at that
point because red the
the flavor of red wine is so
overpowering
i feel like there's some things where
even if even if that tasted amazing i'm
like no this is this is morally wrong
this is too broke for me
like this is so broke
and there's nothing wrong with that i
just don't want to partake in it
you can be broke
no no no it's fine it's fine it's not
poor it's broke it's different broke is
a mindset
poverty and being poor is you you are
just your
be finances is the mindset of like i'm
gonna live like an animal and i you know
i don't i don't partake in that you know
you can be rich but be broke at the same
time
listen the reason why if you're homeless
just no no that's poverty god that's
different there's a difference to
poverty and broke
yeah
big difference guys come on
like there's a difference between he's
trying to get me in a corner here saying
being poor is bad yes it is
i mean you're not doing a very good job
of fighting like
what you're trying to make not my
problems
there's a difference between being ugly
and unattractive
you can clearly afford red wine and you
can clearly afford energy drink why
would you mix them that is like that is
you're making yourself broken for no
reason you know it's not broke that's
broke that's broke